you know how everyone wants these gen
zers to take jobs it's cuz we did I
get it we didn't have options attention
is the number one asset there's a lot of
people in this room that if they were
born in a different era when they were
22 or 23 would have not chosen a minimum
wage job that sucked they would have
just built their business or their brand
Direct on Tik Tok or LinkedIn or
somewhere else these kids are not lazy
they have options they don't want to
make 47,000 a year doing something they
hate they know they can make 47,000 a
year selling T-shirts because of three
viral Tik sucks and I know this is on
everyone's mind it's on everyone's mind
because people are dealing with remote
work we're dealing with what a lot of us
deem as entitlement we can sit here and
on the emerging generation or we
can understand the truth we to build
huge organizations need continuity
people are starting to get other options
there's a lot coming we not them need to
adjust it's the requirements to be a
successful organization from a culture
stpoint in 2023